[Music]
[Applause]
uh this guy used to be a quarterback
steve sarkisian the
texas head coach the former offensive
coordinator at alabama
what kind of quarterback were you steve
well that's a good question i was the
guy that uh
never was never was good enough
physically so i tried to play with my
brain and anticipate throws so
i think i i think i maximized my
potential that's for sure but i found a
way to get completions
and you played in the cfl did you play
in the nfl
no i went straight to the cfl three
years saskatchewan rough riders
they still talk about you there don't
they i'm sure they do
do you still uh still have where's your
alabama gear
uh it's sporadic my son took a lot of it
home
i will say from the uh from the national
championship game i mean he was he was
loaded up so
i've got a couple things with me and
there's a couple things i definitely
want to keep
have a garage sale uh probably doesn't
go over well you know you know how they
do the issued gear they get your name
in the back you know it's kind of like
stark and your locker number
probably wouldn't go over well just
selling selling my gear you've coached
uh some great quarterbacks carson palmer
matt liner
jake locker mark sanchez matt ryan
jalen hurts tuwatonga vailoa mac jones
what is the common thread or theme that
you have that you're looking for in a
quarterback
i think competitive is the first has got
to be the first
uh trait that a great quarterback has to
have he has to have a
competitive innate spirit about him
whether that's on the field whether
that's off the field in preparation
whether that's uh motivating his
teammates
i think if you're not an extreme
competitive human to play quarterback
it's going to be hard for you inevitably
to persevere to lead to do the things
necessary to win
what do you see in mack jones you know i
love his perseverance i love his
competitive spirit
when you think about mac and you guys
i'm sure have documented his story but
to come in as a three-star quarterback
in the same recruiting class as tua
knowing that jalen hurst was just scc
player of the year as a
true freshman and to to not
in this day and age so many guys come in
year one i'm not the starter or i'm not
the backup
they bolt they leave they transfer he
stuck it out
and he stuck it out through jalen he
stuck it out through to uh
he stuck it out when bryce young came in
as the hot shot number one player in the
country
and just continued to work continue to
get better
and at the end of the day i think that
perseverance that mental toughness he
had
not only helped him but i think it kind
of permeated to the rest of our offense
that
you know this is the style of team we're
going to be on offense it doesn't matter
what challenge is in front of us
you know we're going to persevere what's
it like to design a play
knowing that devonta smith is going to
be on the receiving end of that
well it's like is he one of the first
two reads let's start there if he's not
one of the first two reads it's probably
not a very good play design
right uh you know so that was always one
of the one of the key issues but i will
say you know early in the year if you
remember we had jalen waddle devonta
smith
and john metchi things were getting
spread out more when we lost waddle
uh pretty much everything we designed it
was how did it either incorporate
devante smith
or how did it get the defense's
attention to devonta smith so that
other guys could get open and i think he
embraced that role he embraced the
you know he was he was the go-to guy but
he also embraced the
uh you can call it a decoy if you want
to get some other people open i think he
you know
he really went for it help me understand
that we saw the finished product with
davonte smith but at the beginning of
the year i think
most people looked at jalen waddle as
the number one wide receiver
did did the coaching staff view it that
way
no i don't think so at all i think they
were really 1a 1b
um you know devonte had a lot more just
true experience at wide receiver for us
at alabama
you know we knew what we were getting
with him um
waddle was a little bit unique you know
he was really the fourth wideout the
year the previous two years with judy
and rug still there
we all knew the great return the great
returner that he was
and we knew what he could do with the
ball in his hands on offense i think
what people didn't know
was how good of a route runner he was
the versatility to play in the slot
and or outside so we really went at it
with both guys
being the featured receivers i think
he waddle maybe caught defenses a little
by surprise
with his versatility but at the end of
the day there was we knew what devonta
smith was and he was a great player
steve sarkisian the former offensive
coordinator for alabama
uh former offensive coordinator usc head
coach at
uw and now a texas head football coach
tougher to recruit in state or out of
state at texas
probably in state right now um you know
you think we're the university of texas
and everybody just wants to flock and
come to university of texas
you know right now some of the top
talent has left have left the state the
last couple years so i think the first
order of business for us recruiting wise
we have to keep the best players in the
state of texas home and
you know this is their university this
is the great state of texas university
and we got to make sure these these
players stay home you know
once we can solidify that then maybe you
can you can look around outside but
we've got so many
so much great in-state talent our focus
is going to be there and we'll remain
there
uh and if we do some things out of state
it's really regional
or maybe a connection to a coach or a
certain player on the roster
how would you out recruit nick saban
i don't know if you necessarily just out
recruit him i think we've got a great
brand at the university of texas it's an
iconic brand
um it's one with rich history and
tradition we've got tremendous resources
unbelievable support um and the reality
of it is we're going to build something
we're going to build something special
here
i think regionally the kids we can
recruit are a lot closer to us
right in state where at alabama i think
they have to reach a little further
there's not as much going on
in state for them clearly the track
record that coach saban has put together
is is second to none
um but i think we're going to build
something special here and and the plan
is for me to be here for the next 15
20 years so hopefully you're hopefully
you're in interviewing somebody here 15
years from now and asking them the same
question how you can out recruit sarc at
texas
are you guys going to schedule alabama
uh we are scheduled to play him in 2022.
nice i like that how about a m
i i'm hopeful i'd love to play that game
we'll see what happens if i would have
told you five years ago you'd be
the head coach of texas what would you
have said
probably wow uh you know i i didn't know
i didn't know where my career was
necessarily going five years ago right i
just got let go from usc
um there were some dark days you know
you get everybody says you get let go
and you get that you get the paycheck
and yeah
everything's great as a coach you know
it still stings right it's still it's
still
a big old piece of humble pie and i just
had to start to recreate myself as a
coach as a person
and i didn't know if i'd be a head coach
again five years ago
but as the years went on as i started to
work in atlanta
as i got to alabama some more
opportunities came that i that i
said no to um i had a feeling i'd be a
head coach again
um i just wanted to be the right one i
didn't know what the right one would be
clearly when texas called and you looked
at the roster and the resources and
and the athletic director chris del
connie and everybody involved
this was the right one and i jumped at
it but also you have to look at yourself
and and you know you want to continue
your professional career and i had a
moment where i went through this
you know almost two years ago where you
start to go
i got to get better i got to get
healthier
and then people say we can't leave your
job or so
i don't know if you went through that
where you're going i got to kind of
figure out who the hell i
am after usc but i still want to be
in the game so how do you balance that
i just you know what i went to dan was
how do i just be the best version of
steve sarkeesian today
in whatever i was in whatever i was
doing i tried to surround myself with
with great people really supportive
people
um and if it was about being a dad a
husband a coach
a friend whatever that was what what did
the best steve sarkeesian look like
every day and i wasn't worried about
what was going to happen down the road
or where it would lead me it was just
focusing on
today and it was really helpful for me
and i and i think what came out of it
was i became
a lot more thoughtful person i became a
lot more compassionate
i became a lot more aware of the other
people around me and what was going on
in their lives and
um where before man i had blinders on
right i mean i was like just plowing
through whatever's in front of me
because
i wanted to be the best coach i could be
i'm a lot more balanced i think in my
in my approach to life in the end as
i've end up becoming a better football
coach
i'm a lot more aware of our players so
so
the end of it all is whatever happened
in my past there five six years ago
happened for a reason but i truly
believe i'm glad that that happened
because i wouldn't be here today
if those things didn't happen yeah and a
lot of people will hold a grudge or
they're still angry about something that
happened and then they'll blame others
instead of taking inventory with
themselves so
i i applaud you for doing that of just
working on being a better person
you obviously know football and then to
get that opportunity
there um you know it says a lot because
you were willing to go in and say
you know what do i need to do and you
got this head coaching job at texas so
uh congrats on that
if i said you could give urban meyer
some advice on the nfl what would you
say
i don't i don't know if i'm i'm i'm
qualified to give urban meyer advice
if if he just asked if he just said you
know wait what what was the biggest
difference between college and pro when
you were with the falcons what did you
notice here
well i mean at the end of the day there
is no every every
every sunday you show up in the nfl
there is a lot of parody i mean
you're not showing up and and hey you're
a 28-point favorite this week you know
every week
every week that's a that's a touchdown
or less game every week it comes down to
the final two possessions
um those special situations in that
league the two minute drill the four
minute
those critical third downs late in the
game we've all watched nfl football it
seems like they always come down to that
last drive or the last couple drives and
there's no gimmies and and you you know
we got to have our guys ready to play
week in and week out i mean that that
without a doubt is probably the biggest
difference
you don't have any uh texas orange on
what's what's going on here you got blue
there's a little bit of orange in my
button i know you can't see it
man you got to up the uh got to up the
wardrobe here
head to toe i mean come on what are you
doing here
sweat suit track suit something coach
well you know i just spent two years in
alabama where it was a sport coat and it
wasn't a sweat suit from the from the
from the guy that i worked for
so you kind of i guess you get trained
hey well good luck
with this sarc hopefully we'll stay in
touch there and uh you know what
you got a lot of resources there and uh
they've certainly waited a long time for
texas to come back to the prominence
that you know we sort of grew up with so
um
good luck with that thanks dan i really
appreciate it buddy let's uh steve
sarkisian
the new head coach of texas and former
offensive coordinator